- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians.
Welcome to the last and strangest part
of the irregular verb,
the truly irregular.
Yes friends, here I have
compiled all the weirdest,
all of the wooliest, all
the eeriest and spookiest
forms of verbs that don't otherwise
fall into other categories.
So we can't say that they
end with a changed -ed,
we can't say that they end with an -en,
and we can't say that
there's a vowel shift.
We've already covered those.
This is the time for the weird stuff.
First up, -ught.
Huh, what a strange collection of letters
that is to be found in English.
So we take a word like teach,
and in the past tense it's taught.
Likewise, catch becomes caught.
And bring becomes brought.
Yes, that's really strange.
There are only a couple of
words that behave that way.
It's also pretty weird and pretty rare
for there to be a vowel shift
from the present to the past,
and also a "d" sound.
So for example we take the word flee,
which means to run away,
and in the past it's fled.
Likewise in the present, we say say,
and in the past, we say said.
So that "a" becomes "ai",
and the "ee" becomes "e",
and it's this weird vowel
shift that's also followed up
by a "d" sound.
There are some words for
whom time does not exist.
These are verbs for whom the present tense
is the same as the past tense.
Prepare to have your mind blown.
The past tense of bet is bet.
The past tense of set is set.
The past tense of hurt is hurt.
Yeah, it's weird.
Finally, there are some helper verbs,
or auxiliary verbs called
models, that are super weird,
and have these properties
that aren't repeated
anywhere else in English.
So present tense can
becomes past tense could.
I can stand on my head,
or I could stand on my
head when I was five.
May becomes might in the past.
Shall becomes should.
And will becomes would.
And what's super weird about these L's
in could, should, or would,
is listen to me saying them!
You don't pronounce the L's,
and this is the only place in English
where that silent L shows up.
It's so strange!
Ah, I love it!
These are the irregular verbs.
And these, in fact, are the
most irregular of the irregular.
If you can master these, you
will be a grammar champion.
And I believe in you because
you can learn anything.
David, out.